Candid Truth.
What is up everybody? Thank you for
joining us at Candid Truth. We're going
to talk about the truth and we're going
to get candid with it. I just saw this
today. This new Google Deep Mind
technology. This is something that I've
been seeing for a couple of years now.
Ever since AI came out to where you
could just tell AI what you want to see.
Like you become God, right? You type it
and it happens. You say, "I want a
picture of this." And boom, it creates.
Imagine a world where you put on VR
goggles. It's nothing but black. You
speak and things come into existence.
You say, "I had a long day at work. I
want to be on the beach." You're at the
beach. I want it to be sunset. I want
there to be a hot chick. Everything. I
want a pinina colada. Whatever. Anything
you say happens, right? What was the
first deception in the garden of Eden?
What was the first lie Satan told? If
you eat this fruit, what? You will
become as God. The whole deception,
Satan's whole deception from the Garden
of Eden to the new age movement is that
you are God. That you are God within.
That you can reach Christ consciousness.
that you can reach a higher level of of
evolution, a higher plane of existence,
that you can become like God. And that
was what Satan said. He said, "I will be
like the most high." Right? He said, "I
will ascended to the heights of the
clouds." He wants to be God, and he
wants you to think that you can be God.
So, check this out. This is this new
technology called Google Deep Mind. And
this is what I've been predicting. I've
been saying that Satan is going to
create this AI stuff. And look, there's
nothing, none of this is just like
innately bad. Instruments are not bad.
They can be used to play good music or
bad music. TV not bad. You can watch
sermons. You can watch good wholesome
things or you can watch the filth that's
out there. Um, stuff like this,
broadcasting, cell phones. The
technology isn't bad. This technology is
going to help the gospel reach the ends
of the earth. But there's also there's a
spiritual war going on. Satan is trying
to capture your minds. There is a war
for your soul, for your mind,
everything. And so Satan is the god of
this world. He has control over the
majority of what gets pumped out through
that sewage pipe that we call the
mainstream media. And he has control
over even like our channel. uh we get,
you know, shadowbanned and the algorithm
isn't doing what it's supposed to do.
And so it takes a lot of effort to try
and get stuff out there, try to get the
truth out there. And so Satan is going
to create a counterfeit heaven. That's
what he does. He counterfeits everything
of God, right? He's he's not original.
Everything he does is a twisted
perversion of God. And so he's going to
create a counterfeit paradise, a
counterfeit heaven where you can do
whatever you want. And that's what all
these movies are saying, right? Um, all
dogs go to heaven. When he gets to
heaven, the the girl dog says, "Welcome
to doing whatever you wish." And every
Disney movie
says, "You can be in a world where you
can break the rules and follow your
heart." Aladdin said, "I can show you
the world. I can open your eyes. no one
to tell us no or where to go.
Everything, all the movies, all the
propaganda is about taking you to a
world with no rules. The Lost Boys,
right? You can go to Never Neverland and
all this stuff. Satan has been setting
up his counterfeit paradise where there
are no rules and you can do anything in
this virtual world. And now you don't
even have to depend on a programmer to
program your game or whatever. You speak
it into existence. Check this out, man.
This is
mind-blowing. We knew it would get to
this point.
This building across the square looks
quite new. What is that? That is the
Google London office in Panker Square.
This week on 60 Minutes, we reported on
Deep Mind, Google's artificial
intelligence research lab, where we
explored what's coming next with
co-founder and CEO Demis Hassabis, a
leader in this new world. Hello, Scott.
It's nice to see you again. Deep Minds
AI in this new world. I think that's
interesting terminology he used. Um, I
just want to say when I'm saying this
isn't bad, I use AI. I use AI to make
graphics for thumbnails and
presentations and um, I use it for
research. It's a great research tool.
You can actually ask AI, use nothing but
the Bible. The Bible alone, what does
the Bible say about this topic? Boom,
you get all the all the verses. U, you
can say, did did this occultist ever say
anything about this topic? And then you
can compare. You can say, "Hey, can you
give me a list of movies that make God
look like a villain?" You're going to
get it. It's an amazing tool. But
ultimately, technology does land in the
hands of evil. Ultimately,
um, you know,
computers, robots, all this stuff, it is
going to get used by evil. That's why
when um Fukushima happened, all that
radiation was going out into the water
and it was pumping out, pumping out
pump. And they started talking to China
and said, "Will you make humanoid robots
for us that can climb ladders, break
down walls, jump over holes, and turn
valves off so that nuclear waste will
stop pumping into the ocean." And they
said, "No, we don't want to make we
don't want to make a robot that you can
weaponize against us." They were smart
enough to know that if we make this
technology, you will weaponize it. So
that's what I'm saying is the technology
is not bad. It's the fact that we have
evil in us. If there was no evil in the
world, if we lived in a perfect world
with perfect people, technology would
never be used for evil and therefore it
could be used for great things. My
assistant Astra can see, hear, and
analyze the world around it. It can
recognize famous paintings like this
one. That is Edward Hopper's automat and
guess what its subject might be feeling.
What emotion is she exhibiting?
The subject in the painting appears
pensive and contemplative. But with a
little push, it can do even more. Can
you create a story around this picture?
It's a chilly evening in the city. A
Tuesday perhaps. The woman perhaps named
Eleanor sits alone in the diner enjoying
a warm cup of coffee. Have you found
yourself saying I didn't see that
coming? It's happened many times
actually since the beginning of Deep
Mind and Astra. Just being able to be
that good at understanding the physical
world was not something uh we were
expecting it to be that good at that
quickly. While reporting this story, we
learn more about the strides DeepMind
has made with AI that can produce
images, videos, and even
three-dimensional worlds. Two years ago,
we were shown a technology that could
create videos with simple text prompts
like Okay, so if you guys are familiar
with AI at all, like this is stuff a lot
of us use every day. you can tell and
and dude it's getting crazy out there to
where you can't even well some people
can't even tell what's AI anymore now
there are some things that look tricky
but there's like videos out there that
are going viral on YouTube and Facebook
and people like whoa this is crazy and
it's like no this is AI and there's
there's these wars going on like it's
real it's AI and no and people can't
tell anymore you can take any picture
you can run it through a free software
and get a couple seconds of animation
and it can look pretty real. Now, this
is uh I'm not sure they're using
Google Faki. I never heard of that. Text
a video. So, they typed a text that says
golden retriever puppy with wings walks
through a field filled with wild
flowers. I'm going to skip through some
of this because this is kind of old news
to us. This video just dropped two days
ago on 60 Minutes, but look how
realistic this squirrel is. way clearer,
more detailed image and the snowflakes
sort of falling. And the snowflakes
falling. Director of product management
Tom he said the snowflakes are falling
and collecting. So it's not like they're
just it's an animation overlay. It's
literally falling in place in the
atmosphere in the environment. Hume
showed us this model called V2. Exactly.
Yeah.
system will generate it for you and then
you can sort of um immerse yourself in
that in that imagined environment. Okay,
this is where it gets crazy. You can
just imagine any environment the system
will generate it for you and then you
can sort of um immerse yourself in that
in that imagined environment. Basis and
deep mind research scientist Jack Parker
Holder wanted to show us Genie 2, a
world model that uses images to create
interactive 3D environments. This Okay.
It creates I think it's interesting that
they call it deep mind. This thing is
going deep into your mind. The the
brain, the mind is such a powerful
thing. This is what we want to keep pure
and holy. And we want to think on these
things, right? Think on what's pure and
just and holy and true and all those
things because this is how we
communicate with God. And Satan wants to
do everything in his power to distort
this thing. He wants you to be on drugs.
He wants you to be on addictive games.
He wants you to uh be putting music in
your mind that's that's giving you an
evil message with a a poppy beat, right?
He's trying to distort your mind. That's
why Revelation says that the world was
deceived by sorcery. That word sorcery
being pharmarmacia or anything that
medicates the mind. It doesn't just mean
drugs or uh pharmaceuticals. It means
anything that medicates the mind.
Alcohol, they call it spirits for a
reason. It distorts your mind and
invites spirits into your life. And so
this thing is called deep mind. This is
getting into your mind, deep in your
mind. That's what Satan wants to do.
This technology, you can take a
photograph like this, run it through
this program, and it will not only
animate it, but make it a
three-dimensional world that you can
walk in. Check it out. This is a
photograph taken by someone in our team
somewhere in California. And what we
then do is ask Genie to convert this
into an interactive world. So we prompt
the model with this image and Genie
converts it into a game-like world that
you can then interact in. Every further
pixel is generated by a generative AI
model. So the AI is making up this scene
as it goes along. Exactly. Yes. Someone
from our team is actually playing this.
They're pressing the W key to move
forwards. So this is insane because the
game doesn't exist. This game basically
was maybe a somebody typed in make a
game of a paper airplane that's flying
over the Grand Canyon. Now, just because
somebody typed that from their
imagination, now they can actually press
on the keys, control the paper airplane,
and it's flying over Grand Canyon, but
AI is creating every
frame. Meaning, the viewer has no idea
what's coming up next. The world is
being created. It's not a It's not a
game that a bunch of um programmers got
together and said, "Hey, let's make a
game like this and oh yeah, this
creature will be behind that door and
there's a secret back here." No one
knows. Nobody knows what is going to be
happening on this game. It's all a
surprise. It's all a mystery because AI,
artificial intelligence is creating it
real time as you're navigating
around. This is mindblowing.
There was a point I wanted to make about
this. I'm just going to let it roll. And
then from that point onwards, every
subsequent frame is generated by the AI.
Parker Holder told us these models could
eventually train AI agents to accomplish
tasks in these environments.
The point I wanted to make was when I
was growing up in the 90s when Nintendo
came out, Super Nintendo, that was a
different time. You would rent a game
from a store for five bucks or whatever.
You'd have it for two days and you'd
play the game and if you didn't beat it,
maybe you'd rent it again and in a
couple days, four or five days, a week
tops, you beat the game and it's like a
trophy. Like, I beat the game and you
probably don't even play it again. There
were very few games that even had replay
value unless they were co-op two-player
games like a fighter game or something.
And in that situation, you couldn't play
online. It was two people and you were
sitting side by side. Each of you had
controllers and you're there in in each
other's physical space. It's still a
social activity just like playing cards
or just like playing basketball or
anything else. It's just a digital
social game. But now and and the game
would end. Eventually the game ended.
Now guess what? The games never end.
They're endless worlds, endless uh
expansion packs, upgrades. Oh, you can
you're going to level up and level up
and level up and hey, you got a new
weapon. You got a new costume. There's a
new level. Hey, you're in a world with a
thousand people that you don't know.
You're never going to meet in person.
And you might talk to them over a
microphone. But now you can't even trust
is that really their voice or anything.
Right? Eventually, we're not even going
to know if the people we're playing with
online are real people or is it AI
because AI is so advanced already that
you can talk to it and it'll respond to
you just like a real person and you
can't even tell the difference. It takes
breaths. It says, uh, it's doing
everything that humans do. So even right
now, if you're not physically in a room
with somebody, you have no idea if that
person is AI or not that you're playing
with. And so now here's not only do we
have the internet and games that never
end and upgrades and and it's just
they're created purposely to be
addictive. Video game companies are
being sued right now. I keep seeing ads
all the time for they're wanting to sue
these video game companies because
they're purposefully making them
addictive. And no, nothing should be
legal to be addictive like that. Even
though we do have alcohol for sale and
cigarettes and all kinds of
things, addict addictive substances is
not fair. And you know, they used to put
cocaine and Coca-Cola, but eventually
had to take it out, but they just
replaced it with caffeine, another
addictive drug.
The point is the game never ends. You
and and you never figure it out because
the game is building real time right in
front of you and it's going to be
different every time. It's never going
to be the same game twice. We've created
this world with three different arches
where on the left we see some some nice
plants, in the middle it's an opening
which we don't quite know what's in
there and on the right there's a
staircase. And rather than a human
playing, we take um one of our most
capable AI agents and we say, "Can you
actually go up the staircase for us?"
And as it's climbing the stairs, the
genie world model is creating the world
around. So now it isn't even a person
playing. Earlier it was showing that a
person was in control. Now they said
they're talking to the program Genie 2
or something and they're saying, "Hey,
will you go up the stairs for me?" So
now
AI is exploring it itself. It's almost
like two Well, he's going to explain it.
It's basically like you got an AI player
and an AI creator and neither one of
them know what the other's going to do.
The the creator doesn't know what the
what movements the player is going to do
and vice versa. Check it out. It on the
fly instead of imagining what's up
there. Effectively, you got one AI
system playing in the mind of another AI
system. So you got one generating the
world and the other one is moving around
and accomplishing goals in that world
and the practical implication of that
would be what? So of course there's lots
of implications for entertainment and
generating games and videos. But
actually the bigger goal is building a
world model, a model that can understand
our world. You could imagine future
versions creating an almost an infinite
variety of different simulated
environments which the they want to
create an entire world, our world. Uh
you you could use Google maps and tell
AI to to analyze the whole thing. It
would only take a couple seconds, maybe
minutes and now you have a virtual world
of our
world and you never you could go in
there and it could be totally different.
It could be like, it could be like your
city is a real city, but there's people
in there that don't exist, mythical
creatures, whatever. Like, this is
crazy. So, what is going to happen when
people are so addicted to these games or
these chat rooms or whatever you want to
call it, and they enter into this world
where they are God. You enter into the
world and you speak a a world into
existence. I want to be in the world of
Avatar. All of a sudden, you're in there
and you meet a girl, but she's not
somebody else. She's not a
player. This is AI. And you start
building a a friendship with that
AI companion, which they have AI
companions now on Skype and stuff, Zoom.
They're like, "Oh, you want I've never
used it. I just see the button and I'm
like, are you kidding me? Are you
serious?" Like we're so lonely in this
culture now that we're we want an AI
companion. Like I said, it's a great
tool to say, "What does this book say?"
And it saves a lot of time trying to
flip through. I don't want to read a
bunch of new age garbage. I don't want
to read a bunch of occult books, but I
can say, "Hey, does this occult book say
anything about the year 2025 in it?"
Boom. That's what I need. Now, that
saves me a lot of time and trouble and
and reading stuff I I don't even want to
be reading. But imagine if you're in
this world. You never want to come out
because this world is so much better.
You can be whoever you want to be in
this world. You're not the the geeky
loser, out of shape, whatever. You can
be whoever you want to be and and you
can
have an amazing spouse. You can have the
most beautiful woman in the world. You
can have even a a woman that's half
alien or something like an avatar,
right? This is going to be crazy, man.
the the AIs can learn um from and
interact in and then translate that to
the real world. So if you had a
full-sized robot, for example, you
wouldn't train him on how to navigate
the world out in the street in front of
the building. No, you would put him in
this scenario so that he could figure
out how to climb stairs. That's right.
It's much harder to collect data in the
real world, much more expensive, much
slower, for example, robotics data. But
in simulator worlds, you can sort of
collect almost an unlimited amount. We
wondered if Google could use the trove
of geographic data that's at its
fingertips to advance this technology.
Google has access to almost infinite
data. You've got Google Maps, you've got
Street View, you've got Google Earth.
Could all of those data be collected
together in order to train AI agents?
That's what we're exploring at the
moment actually is is um um both ways.
So potentially using street view kind of
data to give real world understanding
and geographical understanding to our AI
systems. Um, and then on the other hand,
you can imagine things like this,
bringing to life static images of real
places, whether it's your own holiday
photos or um actually street view uh
views, which are static currently, and
actually making them interactive and 3D,
so you can look around um the place
itself. Wow. Okay. So, the thing is is
he's saying you can take a photograph,
make it a 3D world, and you can travel
around in there. except it's not going
to be the real picture that you took.
It's going to be it's going to create
some fabricated universe from that
picture.
Um, this is just mind-blowing, guys. I I
knew this is where it was going, but now
that it's here, I'm just like, wow, this
is really crazy. So, what is Google
DeepMind? It says Google DeepMind is
Google Google's AI research lab
dedicated to building AI that benefits
humanity. benefits human. I want to know
in what way because like I said, some of
these tools, they're great for research
and stuff like that. I don't exactly
know how this benefits humanity. They're
talking about training robots in a in a
digital world before they put them into
a real world. I don't even know if that
benefits humanity. What What does it
benefit humanity to have humanoid robots
walking around right
now? Besides, if you are
disabled, they're talking about like
there's going to be one, I don't want to
exaggerate, but at least like one robot
per person in the world. That's not just
like, oh, this is a really cool device
to help people who are are paralyzed.
You would have a lot less robots. So,
how does that benefit humanity?
Uh so the mission says DeepMind's goal
is to build AI systems that benefit
humanity focusing on making AI more
accessible,
responsible, and beneficial to diverse
communities. How are you going to stop
it? This is a open source. Open AI means
that you can let it you can make it do
anything. Right now these programs we
use like chat GBT, they got like guard
rails on there, but if you are a
programmer, you know what you're doing.
You can get rid of all that and there's
no limits on AI and you can upgrade it
and everything. Um, responsibility and
safety. Deep mind is committed to
building AI
responsibly and or with a dedicated team
focused on ensuring safety and ethical
considerations in their AI development
according to the responsibility of
safety
council. Uh, I just I find that really
hard to believe that this is going to
be, you know, that they're going to be
considering all the responsible things.
What is morality to these people?
Where's the moral guideline to people
that are not Christian or don't have the
Bible as their rule of
thumb? If you remember, there was a
movie called Ready Player One. That's
what this movie was about. It was
literally the year 2045. It's only 20
years from now. Uh, the planet is on the
brink of chaos and collapse. H, ring a
bell. We I think we're there. But people
find salvation. Interesting word there.
People find
salvation in the Oasis, an an expansive
virtual reality universe created by
eccentric James Holidayiday. When
Holiday dies, he promises his immense
fortune, blah blah blah. Basically, if
you've seen the
movie, the world is in such a a
situation that nobody wants to live in
the world anymore. Nobody lives in the
real world. Everybody lives in these
trailers that are stacked on top of each
other and they all just sit in their
homes with VR on and they can be
whatever they want to be. The scrawny
guy can be the big built guy. The the
fat dude can be the hot chick. You can
be whatever you want to be. You don't
even have to be human.
And why would you want to live in this
world full of rules and boundaries when
you can live in a world where anything
is possible? Especially when we've been
propagated that our entire lives that we
should want to live in never neverland,
a world with no
rules. So I I
asked, are youth having less physical
relationships? And AI, yes, people some
people want to discredit AI like it's
Wikipedia. AI is actually analyzing all
the websites and getting the most
concise answer. And it says yes,
statistical data indicates a decline in
physical relationships among youth. The
young people are having less physical
relationships. This trend includes
reduced sexual activity, fewer sexual
partners, and less emphasis on romantic
relationships in media consumption. In
media consumption. Several factors
likely contribute to this shift,
including changing societal values, a
focus on education and careers, and the
influence of technology. I think that
plays a huge role. So, they're acting
like, oh, you know, people are just more
uh kids today are they're more focused
on their education and careers. I don't
see that. I mean, dude, I I see bosses
having a really hard time getting
employees to show up to work. Nobody
wants to work. Nobody wants to go to
school. But technology has taken over.
Decreased sexual activity. Surveys and
studies show a decrease in the
percentage of young adults reporting
having sex both in terms of frequency
and number of partners compared to
previous
generations. Influence of technology.
the rise of online dating and virtual
relationships may impact the formation
of physical in-person
connections. So, it's saying virtual
relationships are replacing physical
relationships. And then it says here,
media preference. Young adults are
showing a preference for less emphasis
on sex and romance in television and
movies, indicating a shift in their
entertainment choices. So now they don't
even want to see
relationships on TV because they don't
even they don't connect with that. They
don't what's the word I'm looking for?
Uh they yeah they don't connect with
that. It they don't identify with that.
So it's not it yeah it's not
entertaining to them.
So here it says uh I
asked statistics show increase in Pword.
Yes, statistics indicate an increase in
the Pword consumption particularly
online. Mhm. Over the past few decades,
this trend is driven by increased
internet accessibility and the shift to
mobile viewing. Additionally, the CO 19
pandemic and related lockdowns and
social distancing measures seem to have
further fueled the this increase as one
study reported an 11% increase in this
website viewing in a single month. In
one month. Okay. So, if you guys are
like me and you know about this
pandemic, then you understand that there
is a an agenda behind it.
I do believe that Satan wants to
depopulate the world because a lower
population is easier to control. And so,
how do you depopulate? Well, you make
the LGBTQ lifestyle trendy. You make
transgenderism trendy. You you cause
this pandemic that puts all these uh
restrictions and causes an 11% increase
in the Pword.
Now, now there's a huge decrease in
physical relationships because people
are are preferring virtual relationships
to a physical relationship.
Now, it it said there's a a decrease in
physical relationships, but there's an
increase in the Pword. I don't think
that's a coincidence. I think that's a
trend that's not going to stop. When you
have AI and you can tell AI anything you
want, there's no limits. Whatever you
say, AI will generate it. And you can
you can tweak it like, wait a minute,
that's that feature isn't perfect. Do
this to it. Make it bigger. Make it
whatever, right? This is
crazy. So that that's just a simple
statistic right there that the Pword has
increased.
Now, what does the Bible say in 2 Peter
3:3? It says, "Knowing this first, that
there shall come in the last days
scoffers walking after their own
lusts." So, we know in the last days
lust is going to be running rampant. It
says, I'm going to read the whole thing
here. It says, "This second epistle,
beloved, I now write unto you, and both
which I stir up your pure minds by way
of remembrance, that ye may be mindful
of the words which were spoken before by
the holy prophets, and of the
commandments of us, the apostles of the
Lord, our Savior, knowing this first,
that there shall come in the last days
scoffers." Do we see scoffers? So many
people like, "Where is a sign of us
coming?" Right? walking after their own
lusts and saying, "Where is the promise
of his coming?" Right? For since the
fathers fell asleep, all things have
continued as they were from the
beginning of
creation. For this they willingly are
ignorant. I talked about that on a video
yesterday that we are living in the last
days in the age of technology. We have
no excuse for ignorance. We all have the
world library at our fingertips when at
one time one book costed a fortune. One
book. Now we can look up anything. Every
person has one of these. Even third
world countries, people have a cell
phone. They got dirt floors living in a
shack, but they got cell phones with
internet. So if we are ignorant in these
last days, if Christ returns and we say,
"I I didn't know you were willfully
ignorant." You have to have a desire for
truth. You have to search truth like
gold. And now it's not even that hard.
Yes, there's a lot of disinformation,
misinformation, and and all that stuff
and and censoring, but if you truly
desire to know the truth, you can find
it. Now, easier than ever in history,
that's the truth. And so, here we see
that in the last days, there's people
going to be walking after their lust of
their flesh. They're going to be
scoffing at the idea that Christ is
coming. Are you kidding me? So, they
have no conscience about what they're
doing. Why? Why do they have to have a
conscience? They're not going to be held
accountable for whatever they do, right?
They can do whatever they want with no
accountability because they are scoffing
at the idea that Christ is coming. Are
you
kidding? So, there's something called
maps. I don't know if you know what that
is, but it says maps is defined in this
literature in various and sometimes
contradictory ways, including as a
category of any person with sexual
feelings toward children. MAPS is minor
minor attracted persons.
So, I bring this up because sometimes
you have to use extremes to get through
to people. And and the the truth is this
isn't an extreme. This has already been
being talked about for a couple years
now. I did a show on Little Light
Studios called Gender Babylon like five
years ago that was talking about how
they were trying to normalize maps that
they were showing up at the Pride
parades and mingling in. And you know,
when you start saying,
um, well, you can be any gender you
want. You can identify as anything you
want, then it's only a matter of time
before you say, guess what? May maybe
I'm a 41y old, but I identify as a
12-year-old, and so I want a 12-year-old
girlfriend. And who's going to stop you?
Because now there's hate speech and all
these things and homophobe and
transophobe and all these terms that try
to shut you down for speaking logical,
rational truth. that no grownup should
be with a child or that no male should
be able to enter into a female restroom.
Right? This is just logical, rational
fact and facts don't care about your
feelings. So when you have a world with
no rules and you can do whatever you
want, who wants to live in the real
world? Nobody's going to want to live in
the real world. Already people barely
want to get out of their homes. They
come home from work and they scroll on
Facebook and they click likes and they
look at what other people are doing, but
they don't even get out most of the
time. This is just to show you how real
this is. This is the times. I don't even
want to say the words that are on
screen, but you see it here that these
dolls were on on sale on eBay. This was
back in
2017. And what they said it did was it
was to let me see if I can find
it. It said it
was basically to medicate maps to
medicate those who are minor attracted
persons so that they don't actually have
to act out in the real world. They have
an outlet now that doesn't hurt
anyone. But I don't believe that's
what's going to happen. I don't believe
that you can give um someone who really
wants
drugs a little taste of a drug and then
say, "Okay, now you should that should
hold you over." Right now you don't want
to do drugs. Right? This is like when
people are trying to come off meth and
they get on uh methadone, right?
Methodone clinics. I'm not saying it
doesn't ever
work. Hopefully it does. But you're
you're basically giving a methhead meth
a smaller amount and eventually they're
just going to say, "Look, this isn't
enough. I want the real thing. Give me
the real thing. This is this is insane."
So, just to prove it, Snopes, they love
to debunk conspiracy theories. They're
if it's if it's false, they're going to
find out. And even if it's not false,
sometimes they're going to say it's
false. But right here, it says, "Were
these dolls briefly offered on Amazon?
Fact
check." Yes. true. It was true in March
of
2019. And it says on here, where does it
say it? I'm trying to see where it says
it.
Um, okay. Maybe it's not on
here. Somewhere it does say that this
was
for maps for people, minor attracted
persons. I wish I could find it.
Oh, well. Oh, there it
is. So, that they were clearly meant to
target this P word
here. Look, here it is again. BBC
covered this in
2018. These
dolls and it said that they were
removed, but then they came back up in
days because of a loophole somehow.
And I wish I could find where they
actually say that that's what this was
for. That it was to keep predators from
actually acting
out. Man, what a what a
deception. Oh my goodness. This is So,
what I'm getting at
is we're already dealing with this
problem and now you're going to create a
bigger problem because now you're
saying, "Look, if you just put on your
VR goggles, you can do anything and
you're not going to hurt anybody. You
can go in this VR world and you can take
out that aggression on a virtual
reality, right? You're you're angry at
your wife. Go punch something. Go punch
her in a VR world. You're angry at your
boss.
you can do whatever you want to him in
the VR world and you won't be hurting
anyone. You're just it's just you in the
VR world and nobody can even see it
because you're in your already it said
that the Pword has went up so much
because we went to mobile phones because
remember back in the day you had to get
VHS tape. You had to you had to go into
a store, buy a VHS tape or a magazine or
something. And then it turned
into computers, but they were so
expensive that you had one in the main
room, right? So, nobody's going to be
looking at stuff. Now, everybody has one
in their pocket and they're just walking
around free reign to do whatever they
want. Even children have it. So, people
often ask, "At what age do you think
children should have a cell phone?" And
the answer is whenever you want them to
be exposed to the P-word because it's
only a matter of time before it happens.
Whether they're curious or not, it
sometimes just pops up. They used to say
there was a a time when it said, "Don't
let your children search Spider-Man
because they're going to see the Pword
Spider-Man." And I and I know why
because they get these perverted terms
and they they start trending and now all
of a sudden things that were seemingly
innocent are popping up with explicit
things. And so now your child, it's only
a matter of time. I even me on Facebook,
I can be on Facebook marketplace looking
for a ladder and there's a sponsored ad
that is explicit nudity and I have to
report that thing. I had trouble. Well,
they refused me of of promoting or
paying boosting a video about Trump with
the golden statue Gaza thing. They
denied it because it was political, but
yet somehow blatant nudity numerous
times slips through the crack and
becomes a sponsored ad on the
marketplace. So, that's what I mean.
It's only a matter of time before this
gets into the hands of wickedness.
And so look at this article because when
we start putting
AI VR goggles
on, this is what happens to our brain.
Our brain doesn't tell the difference
between simulation and
reality. It says the efficiency of
simulation and training courses for all
kinds of users and subjects is due to
two main factors. The brain learns more
efficiently when it replicates what it
learns and and
sees. And if the simulation is
realistic, it sees it as the reality.
Well, AI is only getting more and more
real every moment of every day. Whether
it is a flight simulation or a
conversation to improve your leadership
performance. So, I guess this is the
type of things that they say we we're
trying to benefit humanity. Yes. If you
can teach pilots to fly, if you can
teach um if you can use it to practice
being a public speaker, you have a fake
audience and you're just out there
delivering. Yeah, that could actually be
beneficial. Or maybe you're you're
trying out for track or something. I
don't know. But the thing is is we have
something in our minds called mirror
neurons.
and mirror
neurons. It's when it's your brain
firing off everything you do with
physically, whether you're moving your
hand or making a face, your brain fires
a certain way. But even when you see it,
your brain fires off as if you're doing
it. They've done studies like this. It
says this is why you yawn when you see
someone yawning. For example, what works
for basic actions such as smiling and
crying also works for athletic
performance and complex learning. So
oftent times if you see somebody cry,
you'll want to cry. Mirror neurons. If
you see somebody yawn, you want to yawn.
If you see um somebody smiling, you
can't help but smile, right? You see
somebody smile, makes you smile. Mirror
neurons. So this is just scientific
fact. They've been studying this for a
while. This was discovered in
1992 and they did a study where they put
a guy in an MRI and they said or a CT
scan, whatever it was. And they told
him, "We're going to show you some
pictures of people making faces. When
you see the face, make the same face."
And they studied his brain. They said,
"Okay, your brain's firing off this
way." They they analyzed the patterns
that his brain was making when it's
firing off. They put him back in the
machine, showed him the same pictures,
and said, "Don't move a muscle." and his
brain fired off the exact same way as if
he was making the
face. Um, they they accidentally
stumbled on this when they were doing
they had monkeys in cages and they were
giving them peanuts and seeing how their
brain would react. Well, one day a
scientist came in and he he picked up
the peanut in front of the monkey and
the monkeykey's brain started firing off
like he was eating the peanut or as if
he had grabbed the peanut. And the
scientist was like, "Whoa, wait a
minute. That monkeyy's brain fired off
as if he grabbed the peanut when I
grabbed the peanut." And that's how they
found out about these mirror
neurons. So mirror neurons are brain
cells that fire both when an individual
performance
uh performs an action and when they
observe another individual performing
the same action. This activity is to
believe is believed to be fundamental to
social condition imitation learning and
empathy. Empathy you cry because
somebody else cries. Social learning
this is what children are doing. They're
children's minds are like a sponge and
they're looking and they're seeing like
oh you know when I do this they're they
get angry or when I do this they're sad
and and they're learning what those
things mean by looking at it. Studies
have explored mirror neurons in various
contexts including animal behavior,
human cognition, and even their
potential role in certain mental
disorders. So that's that. Now I want to
show you why am I even talking about
this? Why am I talking about mirror
neurons? Because when you're in a
virtual world, people think, hey, if I
do it in the virtual world, it's not me
doing it. It it's fake. That's the
argument people have when they when we
try to tell them, "Look, you shouldn't
be watching wicked movies that glamorize
witchcraft. You shouldn't be watching uh
movies that have adultery or violence in
it." And people are like, "What is the
big deal, man? It's just a movie. It's
not going to change me. I know the
difference in reality and uh in fiction
and fantasy. I never said you didn't."
But the thing is is your brain is
looking at that and your brain is firing
off as if you're doing it. To give a
very explicit example, think about when
people watch the P
word. Is there any physical reaction
happening? Yeah. People watch it and
suddenly things start to happen, right?
So it's not just fantasy. It's not like,
oh, it doesn't affect me. It's just a
movie, bro. It's fiction. No, it's not
fiction. What happens on that screen are
real people, real daughters, real
mothers, and that's exploitation. And
one day, they're going to regret what
they're doing. And you're funding that.
You're supporting that. And that's why I
think it's so crazy that we just saw
that the P-word has actually gone up
because people act like we're we're
getting more humanitarian, we're getting
more woke, and we're we're protecting
people. No, man. PE girls are on Only
Fans now and they got sex. They're
they're making sex work a normal job. I
I read that one in 10 girls are on only
Only Fans. It's becoming so normalized
now that it's just another job. Like,
oh, where do you work? Oh, I'm Only
Fans. Oh, cool. I thought about doing
that. But, you know, this is insane.
This is the world we're living in now.
When you're in this VR virtual AI world
and you can do whatever you want, do you
not think that people's curiosity is
going to be like, "Well, nobody's
looking." I wonder what it would be like
to see this insane thing. I'm going to
be real. When I was a teenager, I used
to go to this website called rotten.com
and
stylepro.com and and watch movies called
Faces of Death.
I was so curious and honestly sadistic
and whatever. I went down a wrong path
and my curiosity and the internet and
all I could find anything I want. I
wanted to see what was it like to see
somebody go through that. And I it's
like you can't even say these words on
uh YouTube right now, but if you if
you're familiar if you're my age, you
know what Faces of Death is.
So, what about when you're in this
world? Does it affect you? Is it bad? Is
it wrong to observe something that is
wrong? Like, okay, I'm not doing
witchcraft. I'm just watching it. I I
like Harry Potter. Okay, I would never
kill anybody, but I just watched
Deadpool where he killed, you know, 300
people. You know, I'm a Christian.
What's the big deal? You know, Deadpool,
he's my favorite character. And that's
not a stretch. I've seen literally
Christians wear Deadpool shirts. We've
lost all our discernment. Psalm 101:3
says, "I will set no wicked thing before
mine eyes. I hate the work of them that
turn aside. It shall not cleave to me."
This is the psalmist. David says, "I
won't set anything wicked before my
eyes." And that was before there was TV.
That was before there was the internet.
He's saying, "Look, if it's wicked, I'm
not even going to set it before my eyes.
I'm not even going to look at that
thing. Matthew 5:28 says, "But I say
unto you," because Jesus said, "You,
you've heard it said that uh to do
this." Well, let me let me look at the
context
here. He said, "Ye have heard it ye have
heard that it was said by them of old
time that thou shalt not commit
adultery.
But I say unto you that whoever lookketh
on a woman to lust after her hath
committed adultery with her already in
his heart. So Jesus is saying, look, you
don't even have to do the act. You are
probably not doing the act because you
know you'll get caught. But if you're
just looking and fantasizing and lusting
in your heart, you've already committed
adultery because sin starts in the
heart.
That's not saying, well, if you went
ahead and fantasized, you might as well
go do it. But it's saying that we need
to take every thought of our imagination
captive into the power of Christ.
Everything like you, you can't just say,
well, I don't do anything externally,
but in my mind, I think about it. I
dwell on
it. He says to look after a woman is the
same. To look after a woman and lust
after her is the same as committing
adultery. So you can't say that fiction
or you know it's fantasy it's not real.
It doesn't affect
me. It's committing
adultery. Romans 1:32. This is this is a
really clear passage because it says who
knowing the judgment of
God that they which commit such things
are worthy of death. What kind of things
are worthy of death? Sin. The wages of
sin is death. Which witches were to be
stoned to death. witchcraft is going to
get death. It says those who will not
inherit the kingdom are liars,
fornicators, effeminate,
homosexuals,
murderers. And it says, "So if you do
those things, you're worthy of death.
That which commit such things are worthy
of death." But then it continues, "Not
only do the same, but have pleasure in
them that do them." So now it's saying,
look, you might say, I would never kill
anybody, but are you taking pleasure in
watching a violent movie? Are you taking
pleasure in a violent video game where
you're literally walking around
murdering people? This is a virtual
simulator. Remember, they teach people
to fly airplanes, to drive cars using
simulators. And then people will spend
hours, hours. I mean, I'm telling you,
especially if people get paid to play
games, hours upon hours of their life in
a virtual murder
simulator, and they think, "It's just
fantasy. I'd never kill anybody." What
does the word say? To look after a woman
to lust after her is the same as
committing adultery in your heart. To
hate to look at a brother, to hate a
brother is the same as murder. And yet
you're virtually taking pleasure blowing
people away. It says, "Not only them
that do the same, but have pleasure in
them that do them." If you're watching a
movie where somebody is murdering
somebody and you take pleasure in that,
you're guilty of murder. If you're
watching someone where somebody's
committing adultery and you're getting
pleasure out of that, you're guilty.
You're worthy of death. This is strong
warning. We need to be walking the
straight and narrow. We need to pick up
our cross daily and die to the lust of
the flesh. We need to get rid. We need
to be separate from this world. This
world has made everything so acceptable
and cultural that pop culture and trendy
that it's okay. Look, even 50 years
ago, if you would show, if you would
time travel someone from 50 years ago or
the
1920s, and drop them in our world today
and say, "Hey, let me show you a video
game." They would probably have a heart
attack or say, "Hey, let me show you
this movie. It's called Deadpool. It's
really cool. They they actually have
toys of it in the kids aisle at
Walmart."
It's mindblowing where we've come, how
how desensitized we've become. And it's
the frog in the kettle. It's the frog in
the boiling pot. And they're turning up
the heat. Satan's turning up the heat a
little each generation, pushing the
boundaries every time. The older people
are like, "No, they shouldn't be doing
that." And the kids are like, "Ah, you
don't get it, mom." And then the next
generation, same thing. I was the one
saying, "You don't get it, parents. Mom
and dad, you don't get it. Like, this is
this is the new thing." And now I'm
cringing at what's happening in our
world. Each generation does the same
thing. Gets worse and
worse. Matthew 4:9 says, "And saith unto
him, all these things will I give thee
if thou will fall down and worship me."
Satan was offering something to Jesus.
He said, "If you bow to me, I'll give
you everything. I'll make you a god on
this earth." And millions of people have
taken that same offer
today. There are tons of celebrities.
There are tons of rich elitist who are
living like gods on earth. They don't
have to. They got more money than they
can spend in their entire life. They can
go anywhere they want. And nobody's
going to charge Justin Bieber for his
plate. No, it's on the house, right?
They're getting everything for free.
They can have any man or woman that they
want. They got all more money they can
ever spend. But what profits a man to
gain the whole world and lose his very
soul? Right? Satan can offer you all the
kingdoms of the world. You can be a god
on this earth, but guess what? Your time
is ticking and one day you're going to
have to face judgment. And there's no
greater gift than eternal life in a
perfect world. No more pain, no more
sorrow, no more wickedness. I long for
that.
I'm I This is not my home. I long for
that perfect world. I'm sick of the
things of this world. I've had a taste
of all of it. Don't act like I've never
been there. I've had it all. And all of
it is vanity. Vanity. I don't want it
anymore. I'm disgusted by it. When I see
people drink a beer, I'm disgusted. When
I see people spark up a joint, I used to
love it. I want to throw up. I hate it.
It's destroying lives. It's it's taking
souls to hell. I don't want it anymore.
Satan can give you all the things of
this world, but he cannot give you
eternal life. And in fact, he's going to
take your eternal life. Matthew 24:37
says, "But as in the days of Noah were,
so shall also the coming of the Son of
Man be." What were the days of Noah
like? They were violent. It says only
evil thoughts continually were going
through their mind and they were
violent. And I look at the world today
and and the the majority of video games
are are violent video games. Violent and
satanic games like Diablo, games like
Call of Duty. I mean, even Call of Duty
is supposed to be this military game
which is violence, but now they're
incorporating Satanism where you can
sacrifice somebody on a pentagram. I've
seen it. Somebody sent people send me
stuff all the time and say, "Have you
seen this? Have you seen this?" This
world is getting more violent and
satanic every day as in the days of
Noah. What else does it say in Luke
17:28? It says, "Likewise also as it was
in the days of Lot, they did eat and
they drank and they bought and they sold
and they planted and builded." This is
talking about they're going on with life
as usual. Look, this is just normal
everyday life. But as in the days of
Lot, this was the the cities of Sodom
and Gomorrah. And what was that? Sexual
sin rampant as well as violence. It was
wickedness all around, just like Noah.
But specifically, people think of sexual
sin when it comes to this. Now, what do
we see? I mean, every magazine at a at
the grocery store has a woman barely
dressed. You can drive down the street
and see a billboard with
a a a billboard for plastic surgery. And
it's like, I can't believe they can show
that on a
billboard. And this is where this is
going. This is where our world is
heading right now.
Matthew 24:12 says, "And because
iniquity shall abound and the love of
many wax cold, iniquity is the word
lawlessness." We're coming to a time
where lawlessness will abound. Only
thoughts, only wicked thoughts
continually. And and even today, things
that we don't even consider wicked were
wicked 100 years ago when people still
had a morality to them, when they
weren't desensitized. We see things on
TV and we're just like, "Oh, yeah,
that's normal. That's normal." It's not
normal. Lawlessness shall abound and the
love of many shall wax cold. That makes
me think of all these people that don't
have any kind of physical, social
partners anymore. The love of many will
wax
cold. 2 Corinthians 2:1 says, "Lest
Satan should get an advantage of us, for
we are not ignorant of his devices."
I'm showing you this because this is one
of Satan's devices that's coming. And I
don't want anyone to fall prey for his
devices, his traps, because I already
have been there. And I grew up in a time
when it wasn't near this bad. It was it
was already bad. I mean, I I was I
idolized Marilyn Manson, Ninh Nails, and
it was bad. Like I told you, I was
looking up websites showing faces of
death and all that stuff. But the world
has gotten 10 times worse since then. I
didn't live in a time where I could type
anything I wanted. And even if it
doesn't exist, now it exists. That's the
thing. We live in a world right now,
well, five years ago, where you could
only see or play or listen to things
that existed, things that somebody
created. Um, a musician had to create
it. A a game designer had to create it.
A movie producer had to create it. But
now you are the creator. You are God.
You're the God of this world. That's
what Satan is offering. You get to be
God. You speak it into existence.
Something that's never existed before.
And that can be music. I can go right
now on Sunno and I can make a song about
anything I want. It can be good or bad.
I can go to uh chat GBT and I can write
a script about a movie that I'd never be
able to I'm not a screenwriter but with
chat GBT I can write a script and then I
can use ChatGBT to make an image that's
never existed. I can make a movie. I can
make scenes of things that never
existed. And soon we're going to be
wearing VR headsets and creating 3D
worlds of whatever you want your
imagination. Remember the the hearts,
their imagination of their hearts were
only evil continually. Do we live in a
time where it's like Sodom and Gomorrah,
the days of Lot? Do we live in a time
where it's the days of Noah? Do we live
in a time where people's hearts are only
evil continually? And now Satan's
saying, "Here you go. You can create
whatever you want. Put it on and go to
never neverland." I hope this was eye
opening to you. I hope this shows you
the signs of the times that we're living
in because things are about to get
crazy. We're not going to be able to
tell fiction from re reality soon. I
mean, it's already the line is being
blurred and now everyone's going to be
living in their fantasy world and doing
the most sickest things that their
heart's desires can do. Following the
lust of their flesh and and won't be
held accountable by anyone except God.
It's just going to be between them and
God. And they will be held accountable
for what they've done. Jesus is coming
soon. We are living in the last days
where there's scoffers saying, "Where is
the sign of his coming?" The signs are
all around. Look around. The signs are
everywhere. If you like this video,
please give it a thumbs up. We are not
monetized. YouTube has rejected us twice
when we've applied for monetization
because we are harmful content. YouTube
does not want this message getting out
there. So, please give it a thumbs up.
We can only do this because of
supporters like you. If you would like
to support this ministry from anywhere
from a dollar to $1,000, every little
bit helps. Go to
candidtruth.org. You can donate through
many different methods. If you like
t-shirts, we got lots of cool t-shirts
and we get about $5 per sale on that
shop. We can't do this without you
guys. We can't do this without you guys.
Thank you all who are supporting so that
we can continue to do this. And also, I
forget to mention this all the time, but
we go and speak at churches. So, if you
would like Candid Truth to come to your
church and give a presentation on aliens
or media or health or any of those
topics, just give us a call. You can go
to candidtruth.org and you can actually
schedule us to come to your church. We
love you. We thank you guys and we'll
see you next time on Candid Truth.